[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du Grand JT des
territoires voici tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité avec à la une
cette semaine les suites hivernales des
feux de forêts survenu cet été alors que
les vagues de chaleur sont oubliés les
collectivités s'affairent pour la
reforestation et la sécurité de tous
reportage de Télé 7 la chaîne du groupe
sud-ouest dès le début de ce journal il
est organisé comme chaque année le
premier week-end du mois de décembre le
Téléthon est un moment unique de
solidarité pour la recherche après de
Rennes des bénévoles travaillent depuis
deux ans à la restauration d'un véhicule
pour récolter les fonds la rédaction de
TVR s'est glisser dans leur garage il
représente l'art de vivre à la française
certains des meilleures cuisiniers du
pays concourrés pour le titre de
meilleur ouvrier de France un concours
sous les yeux d'un jury prestigieux
auquel a assisté télé Grenoble du
savoir-faire aussi dans les airs à la
fin de ce journal le département de
l'Aube accueillait il y a quelques jours
une rencontre internationale
d'aéromodélisme d'intérieur un
rendez-vous fait de détails et de
voltige vous allez le voir avec la
rédaction de Canal 32
voilà des dizaines et des dizaines de
milliers d'hectares partis en fumée les
forêts françaises vous le savez n'ont
pas été épargnés par les incendies cet
été près de quatre mois plus tard leur
état l'automne et à la préparation déjà
des espaces verts environ de le
département le plus touché par les feux
un chantier spectaculaire vient de
débuter la battage des arbres calcinés
un travail nécessaire pour le
reboisement et la sécurité publique un
reportage d'Ivan branchis pour TV7 la
chaîne du groupe Sud-Ouest en Gironde
[Musique]
les arbres tombent à la chaîne
et cette route habituellement très
fréquentée par les touristes se
transforment peu à peu en un grand champ
de bataille
la circulation est interdite au public
pour laisser travailler cet abatteuse à
l'aide de cette grosse pince Jonathan
coupe et arrache les arbres calcinés
pour sécuriser la zone du
lacs et beaucoup ils sont pourris donc
il faut faire attention comment on fait
la bataille parce que on peut bien bien
sûr les avoir sur la machine chaque jour
de 6h à 18h tous les arbres marqués sont
abattus un arbre déjà fragilisé par les
incendies mais également attaqué par des
parasites une lutte contre la montre est
alors enclenchée
il y aura beaucoup d'arbres que je vais
pas pouvoir les faire parce qu'elles
sont trop grosses trop vieilles voilà
sont difficiles dangereuses et lui s'il
est tout seul
il va prendre beaucoup de temps tout ça
ça va partir dans des usines différentes
là on fait trois quatre produits un
travail d'équipe qui doit s'effectuer
sur l'ensemble de la route du lac avant
d'abattre les arbres des parkings
voilà un travail salutaire pour les
forêts et leur avenir dans le Sud-Ouest
justement certains des espaces touchés
par des incendies il y a plusieurs
années sont en pleine reforestation un
processus naturel mais pas que
l'intervention de l'homme est parfois
nécessaire pour les plantations exemple
dans le Gard avec ce sujet de Loris
chamerlat pourvie Occitanie regardez
c'était en juillet 2019 500 hectares
partaient en fumée sur le plateau des
Costières dans le Gard trois ans plus
tard leur est à la reforestation
avec les petits écoliers de général
venus prêter main forte
la forestation parce que sans arbre on
peut plus respirer sur les 500 hectares
parties en fumée 70 sont communaux et
bénéficie d'un projet de reforestation
on prend toujours le temps de laisser
faire la nature c'est notre premier
principe sur les 70 hectares il y a 50
hectares qui se régénèrent naturellement
c'est-à-dire que vous avez
donc dérogé beaucoup de chaînes
énormément parce que le chêne en reparle
sous forme végétative et le fait que les
racines étaient dans le sol elles ont
pas brûlé par contre on a 28 hectares où
on a ni régénération ni qui pousse donc
là on a décidé d'intervenir de planter
dans 50 ans vous aurez les chênes verts
qui toute la partie chêne vert aura bien
repoussé 1100 arbres sont plantés par
plus tard avec de la diversité et des
essences plus résistantes enfin pignon
pin d'Alep ou encore chêne vert et
chêne-liège
qui doit permettre une lutte aussi
contre les incendies plus facile prévoir
un système de chemin DFCI qui permet aux
pompiers d'intervenir aussi dans de
bonnes conditions et puis après toutes
les questions d'entretien la ville de
Générac a estimé un budget des travaux
Salvan à 539000 euros dont près de
100.000 euros de dents de mécène
tout à fait autre chose Thierry Zaveroni
était l'invité exceptionnelle jeudi
matin de l'émission Face au territoire
sur TV5 Monde le nouveau Grand Maître de
la Grande Loge de France a notamment
évoqué l'implication des francs-maçons
dans la société regardez cette extrait
vous êtes vous les Francs sur
l'humanisme vous êtes sur les valeurs
humanisme de l'humanisme quelle est la
position des des frères des
francs-maçons de la Grande Loge de
France sur la corrida alors il faut
rappeler que nous sommes un ordre
tradition initiatique de spiritualité
humanisme et donc la tradition de la
corrida ça nous parle j'ai eu l'occasion
dans ma jeunesse de de pouvoir assister
à des corridas c'est un moment très
particulier je crois que aujourd'hui
plus que jamais il faut qu'on soit aussi
attentif à la souffrance des animaux et
que je crois que chacun doit avoir le
libre arbitre et essayer de
jamais exprimé sur ce sujet c'est la
première fois que que donc au dignitaire
maçonnique dit clairement sur ce plateau
en direct ce matin que vous êtes contre
la corrida en fait moi si vous voulez
aujourd'hui je suis contre la souffrance
animale et dans la dans la corrida il y
a une souffrance animale mais je suis
aussi respectueux d'une compétition du
18ème siècle qui nous vient d'Espagne et
je crois que il faut laisser aux uns aux
autres cette capacité de discernement de
savoir si effectivement il faut
continuer face au territoire avec
Thierry Zaveroni le nouveau Grand Maître
de la Grande Loge de France est avoir ou
à revoir sur le site internet de TV5
Monde et des partenaires de l'émission
Ouest-France Nice-Matin france-anti et
20 minutes tout à fait autre chose se
déplacer pour un rendez-vous médical
faire ses courses ou pour n'importe quel
autre raison cela peut s'avérer très
compliqué quand on vit à la campagne
c'est justement pour aider les personnes
les moins mobiles que l'association
Solidarité transport
œuvrent dans les Vosges grâce à des
chauffeurs bénévoles celle-ci permet à
ces bénéficiaires de Noël rendez-vous un
reportage de Thierry Lasson et de Andy
Dieppe télévision
on y va c'est parti cela n'a l'air de
rien mais à bientôt 78 ans Daniel qui
réside à l'éponge sur Vologne a pris la
route direction décimons pour y
retrouver Marie-Odile cette dernière ne
peut plus conduire et dans quelques
minutes elle a un rendez-vous médical à
20 km de la à bruyère Daniel fait partie
de l'association Solidarité transport
qui depuis sa création en 2018 s'attaque
au problème de mobilité en zone rurale
vous savez le train il passe pas dans
tout les villages les bus ne passera
dans tous les villages les rendez-vous
médicaux
ça peut être n'importe quand solidarité
transport compte actuellement 20
chauffeurs pour près de 170
bénéficiaires à elle seule et rien que
cette année Daniel a parcouru près de
3000 km au profit de personnes
dépourvues de moyens de locomotion mais
l'important est également ailleurs
important pour les gens pour les
personnes qu'on transporte et c'est
important pour moi aussi c'est beaucoup
de relations humaines beaucoup
d'échanges parce qu'il y a pas que la
précarité sociale monétaire et à la
précarité de l'âge j'avais une voiture
avant que j'ai dû vendre parce que je
pouvais plus conduire du fait que
j'aurais été un danger public pour les
autres et pour moi tout le monde est
satisfait l'association pour sa
trésorerie peut compter sur une
cotisation annuelle de 5 euros par
membre qu'il soit bénéficiaire ou
chauffeur ces derniers sont aussi
défrayés raison de 50 centimes d'euros
du kilomètre solidarité transport c'est
depuis le début de l'année plus de 29300
km parcourus mais un manque crucial de
bénévoles un concept qui fait école une
structure
identique s'est créé dans le Jura et le
Pays basque sont également intéressés
solidarité encore dans ce journal avec
le Téléthon organisé les deux et trois
décembre prochain par tout en France
l'événement qui permet chaque année de
récolter des fonds pour la recherche
contre les maladies rares reposera une
nouvelle fois sur l'action de milliers
de bénévoles près de Rennes vous allez
le voir des passionnés de mécaniques ont
travaillé pendant deux ans pour
restaurer un véhicule des années 60 un
travail titanesque et une mise à la
vente prévue au profit du week-end
solidaire une belle histoire que nous
raconte Natacha Store pour thé vert à
Rennes
passer de ça à ça c'est le défi que
s'est lancé l'association taco et turbo
de stredel depuis plus de deux ans la
trentaine de bénévoles bichonnent cette
Simca Ariane 4 de 1961 pas besoin d'être
en fin connaisseur le but c'est surtout
de venir tous les samedis matin pour
apprendre j'ai des petites notions
mécanique mais très faibles en toute
humilité on a produit soudage on apprend
justement des ajustements du montage
mécanique du fonctionnement aussi de la
voiture et on apprend beaucoup de choses
l'association vend des tickets à
seulement 10 euros pour faire gagner
cette Simca lors d'une grande loterie
tous les fonds seront reversés à l'AFM
Téléthon 2000 billets ont déjà trouvé
acquéreur mais il en reste encore
beaucoup vu l'investissement de toute
l'équipe de bénévoles après 1600 heures
effectivement on aura tous un pincement
au cœur lorsqu'elle partira on l'a tous
un petit espoir en tête c'est qu'elle
circule autour du secteur et qu'on est
la chance de l'avoir encore rouler que
ce soit pour la voiture ou pour les
11000 euros de pièces l'association n'a
rien dépensé et ne fonctionne que grâce
au don on a un donateur qui nous a donné
beaucoup de pièces neuves c'est lui qui
nous a fourni tous les pistons tous les
joints après le dernier ajustements et
coup de pinceaux viendra à la phase
d'essai et de réglage pour savoir si
vous serez le repropriétaire rendez-vous
le vendredi 2 décembre pour le tirage à
la Guerche de Bretagne
allez restons les mains dans le cambouis
dans cette édition pour parler à présent
de formation dans la Sarthe une nouvelle
voie professionnelle vient de voir le
jour le garage école l'idée est simple
placer les élèves en situation réelle
les jeunes apprentis et par ainsi les
véhicules déposés au garage le tout
encadré bien sûr par des professeurs des
tailles et explications avec Anthony
Python et Florian vosniak pour LM TV
Sarthe
c'est pas des petits coups c'est
vraiment un coup sec et ça marche le
premier cours à prendre la prise en main
des outils ces jeunes constituent la
première promotion du garage école du
Mans un nouveau concept de formation à
la mécanique pour des élevages de 15 à
18 ans passionnés d'automobile
je suis venu ici parce que j'ai trouvé
que ça aurait pu être cool de travailler
avec des nouvelles personnes en groupe
surtout de mon âge pour qu'on puisse
mieux apprendre ensemble et mieux
comprendre même si on a qu'on plus de
connaissances il nous permet directement
de nous mettre dans en immersion en fait
donc c'est ça c'est intéressant et puis
de se dire que au pire des cas ce ne met
pas de pression de se dire que si on a
fait quelque chose de mal bah il y a du
monde derrière pour nous encadrer car
c'est tout l'intérêt de ce type de
formation à prendre en faisant les
élèves vont devoir réparer les voitures
de vrais clients tout en étant encadré
par des professeurs le programme est
exactement le même que dans les
formations en alternance ou les lycées
professionnels
le BA de la mécanique le frein les
trains avant le fonctionnement du moteur
d'une boîte de vitesse
essence diesel mais aussi vont faire des
stages en interne sur le tombeau
d'aujourd'hui donc un peu sur les
véhicules électriques qui brillent
hydrogène le garage écoles du Mont fait
partie des écoles de production un
réseau d'établissement privé qui
travaille en collaboration avec les
branches professionnelles on a à la fois
le paradoxe dans la société française
aujourd'hui c'est que 100000 jeunes
chaque année qui au fond sont un peu
dans une voie sans issue et en même
temps des filières et notamment la
filière automobile mais c'est vrai dans
d'autres filières également qui ne
trouvent pas les salariés qu'ils
recherchent ou non c'est tout le secteur
de l'automobile qui s'implique dans le
garage école la Fédération
professionnelle des réparateurs autos
figure même parmi les premiers
investisseurs
voilà il n'y a pas que le secteur
automobile qui tente de séduire les plus
jeunes celui du bâtiment aussi comme
vous le voyez sur ces images des
étudiants de la loi étaient invités à
résoudre quelques énigmes dans le cadre
d'un BTP game l'occasion pour eux de
découvrir différents métiers de manière
ludique et pédagogique maçon
chauffagiste ou encore électricien le
manque de main d'oeuvre et criant dans
ce secteur images fournie par nos
partenaires de TL7 dans la Loire
du chantier au fourneau direction la
ville de Grenoble dans cette édition
pour découvrir à présent les coulisses
d'un prestigieux concours celui du
Meilleur Ouvrier de France meilleur
ouvrier de France MOF pour les initiés
ils étaient 30 à vouloir décrocher la
précieuse collerette tricolore des
participants qui ont dû exposer leur
virtuosité culinaire devant un jury pour
le mois prestigieux vous allez le voir
reportage de Lucile Dailly pour Télé
Grenoble
le geste trahit l'ébullition dans un
dernier instant de sang-froid le chef
Alain Ducasse brise le silence à huit
reprises dans une salle d'acclamation de
l'arme et de sourires perplexes ces 8
noms seront inscrits sous une collerette
tricolore convoité depuis des mois des
années par ses cuisiniers qui ont tout
donné pour incarner le plus haut niveau
d'excellence à la française devenir l'un
des meilleurs ouvriers de France
un niveau d'exigence que l'on juge déjà
au nombre de tocs blanches qui circulent
silencieusement dans les cuisines du
Clos d'or durant deux jours les 30
finalistes parmi 515 candidats ont
exécuté leur partition millimétrée pour
réaliser l'alchimie d'une gastronomie
ultra codifiée mais qui grandit avec les
époques on n'est pas dans le classicisme
on est dans la tradition qui évolue avec
son temps et avec on va dire les
courants d'influence qui font que la
cuisine française évolue aussi
aujourd'hui on est avec des recettes
complètes ou le candidat doit donner sur
ce qui est imposé mais aussi une part de
liberté la liberté c'est une nuit une
épice l'expression d'un critère ce qui
est imposé trois plats
Omar mer et jardin noisette de chevreuil
et couronne de à la neige on note la
présentation les goûts les textures mais
aussi l'organisation la méthode et les
nouvelles contraintes c'est quelqu'un
qui est réactif qui arrive enchaîner les
tâches et qui aussi arrive à gérer des
commis parce qu'il y a la partie
management qui est important et à la
partie également éco-responsabilités les
gestes aujourd'hui qui sont importants
une expérience une chance inespérée pour
les élèves du lycée hôtelier de Grenoble
qui accompagne les candidats devant un
jury de prestige à l'inducas le
président Régis Marcon Paul Perret
Philippe Etchebest Virginie basselot et
tant d'autres légendes de l'art
culinaire qui donne de la lumière sur
cette ville de Grenoble qui pourrait
sortir de l'ombre de sa réputée voisine
lyonnaise et peut-être verra-t-on
fleurir la truite à la Grenobloise et
son gratin dauphinois réinterprété dans
les assiettes de la 28e édition le jury
peut y réfléchir pendant quatre ans mais
cette aventure a d'ores et déjà projeté
la capitale des Alpes dans l'histoire de
la haute gastronomie
la cuisine qui s'exporte aussi dans
l'espace la preuve avec ce partenariat
que vient de signer notamment le chef
étoilé Thierry Marx pour la recherche et
le développement de l'alimentation
spatiale une thématique étonnante dans
laquelle le célèbre cuisinier est déjà
investi avec la confection de repas pour
l'astronaute Thomas Pesquet ce nouveau
partenariat était également l'occasion
de présenter une imposante machine de
production alimentaire sans eau inventée
par une jeune entreprise toulousaine
image et propos recueillies par Clément
cassis pour nos partenaires de la
Dépêche du Midi sur place
on est ce qu'on appelle sur un système
hors sol donc vous voyez que si je
soulève ici donc ça qui est du chou kale
si je soulève on a absolument rien donc
c'est simplement on arrosant avec la
solution nutritive les racines on va
apporter la nourriture au plante pas
oublier que un astronaute il vit en
aguilie en gros il vit comme si vous
aviez le nez bouché par un rhume donc il
faut donner beaucoup de relief à
l'alimentation et Thomas ne souhaite pas
d'exhausteur de goût donc il faut le
faire de façon naturelle pour qu'il ait
vraiment cette sensibilité à la
dégustation aller retour sur terre ou
plutôt sur l'eau dans ce journal avec
l'inauguration titanesque d'un ascenseur
pas comme les autres un ascenseur à
bateau la nouvelle plateforme aux
dimensions impressionnantes comme vous
le voyez sur ces images du journal La
Marseillaise nos partenaires permettra
notamment de faciliter la maintenance de
ce yacht pesant jusqu'à
4300 tonnes sur les chantiers navals de
La Ciotat un équipement unique en son
genre qui a nécessité deux ans et demi
de travaux pour un coup à peu près de 80
millions d'euros
alors autre chose patron de presse passé
par de nombreuses rédactions George
Ghost est aujourd'hui à la tête de VSD
un magazine devenu mensuel dans lequel
beaucoup de reportages sur les
territoires sont faits il la relancé
après des années très compliquées
Christophe Rigaud s'est rendu dans les
locaux de ce journal pour en savoir un
peu plus sur cette recette à succès
regardez sur portage
la tribune le Nouvel Économiste François
et aujourd'hui VSD George gone est un
patron de presse qui aime les défis
l'homme d'affaires rachète le titre au
groupe Prisma en 2018 VSD est alors en
difficulté et c'est avec sa casquette de
journaliste que George gone décide de
poursuivre l'aventure du magazine j'ai
voulu en faire mensuel pour me battre
contre l'Internet parce que l'Internet
même les deux au fond est menacé par
l'Internet à ce moment ça habite l'info
le quotidien est menacé mais ils font
eux-mêmes l'Internet donc ça va ils sont
sur le net VSD ne peut plus être qu'un
mensuel parce que ça va c'est le copieux
évidemment
à la fois people mais surtout politique
irrévérencieux sport extrême
l'adrénaline comme on dit chez nous
Venezia a toujours été proche et
toujours été un petit peu à rebrousse
pour elle une ligne éditoriale à
contre-courant est très offensive
assumée par le patron du magazine
on est en dehors de la bien-pensance
surtout en dehors du politiquement
correct et souvent je vais chercher dans
l'histoire les vrais raisons
défaites à chaque numéro à la dernière
page du magazine figure un nom bien
connu du journalisme Philippe Bouvard à
92 ans le journaliste livre son humeur
ses pics et son humour inoxydable sur
l'actualité toujours été irrévérencieux
drôle satirique et humble il a donc une
page entière qui lui est confiée où il
dit sont faites et avec son humour
habituel son intelligence et sa vivacité
une chronique ou Philippe Bouvard traite
de ces sujets de prédilection mais pas
que c'est essentiellement de la
politique parce que c'est quand même un
observateur fin de la hippolytique
française donc le coeur de ces de ces
sarcasmes et de ses critiques c'est
souvent les hommes politiques pour
autant il parle de phénomènes de société
je gâche que dans les prochains numéros
ils nous sont pas des féministes éco
féministes et du combat pour la planète
Philippe Bouvard n'a pas encore accroché
les gants et livre chaque mois c'est
bouvardages dans VSD un regard acéré
critique et drôle sur notre société où
tout va toujours plus vite
c'est une pratique aussi ancestrale que
théâtrale la Moura est un jeu
méditerranéen vivant et parfois très
bruyant mais connu d'une grande partie
du public cette activité se joue à
l'aide des mains et repose sur
l'addition de nombres un jeu étonnant
comme vous le voyez sur ces images de
nos confrères de via télé paisé l'île de
Beauté accueillait d'ailleurs il y a
quelques jours la quatrième édition
d'une rencontre interrégionale dédiée à
la Moura propos récoltés par Cyprien
rebaté et Loïc Le Prince
c'est un jeu d'addition en fin de compte
qui a été inventé en même temps que les
chiffres ça fait à peu près 5000 ans
c'est un jeu surtout populaire c'était
un jeu populaire puisque tout le monde y
jouait il y avait pas autant de jeux que
maintenant je dirais et c'est un jeu qui
revient je dirais maintenant ou du moins
ça fait quelques années finalement c'est
pas tellement les règles du jeu qui sont
intéressantes mais c'est ce que le jeu
véhicule chez nous c'est un jeu de
pêcheur donc c'est très lié à la mer
c'est un jeu chez nous qui est traité
astral on va avoir d'autres endroits de
la Méditerranée coin Serda mais ça va
être un jeu beaucoup plus musical ça
reflète un peu la personnalité du
territoire etc
voilà moins bruyant peut-être mais tout
aussi intéressant à la pratique de
l'aéromodélisme d'intérieur était mise à
l'honneur il y a quelques jours du côté
de Troie l'objectif de ce rendez-vous
aérien et international c'est partager
le goût d'une même passion et donner de
la visibilité à une discipline
minutieuse et étonnante vous allez le
voir avec ce reportage de Canal 32
pour participer à ce rassemblement
troyen de vol indoor ou aéromodélisme en
salle certains n'ont pas hésité à faire
de la route parmi la trentaine de
pilotes présents certains viennent
d'Allemagne ou encore de Belgique c'est
un des rares rassemblements indoor en
France et même en Belgique ça nous tient
je dirais à coeur de participer quoi
c'est après le succès de le premier
édition que les organisateurs ont choisi
de reconduire l'événement un
rassemblement placé sous le signe du
partage avoir des échanges avec avec
d'autres pilotes avec d'autres
constructeurs parce que il y en a
beaucoup qui construisent eux-mêmes leur
avion quand on voit ce qu'il y a sur
l'étape c'est vraiment joli au total une
centaine d'avions sont présents dans le
gymnase certains ont été entièrement
construits par leurs propriétés comme
cette demoiselle de 1908 c'est une
reproduction d'un avion qui est un des
premiers ULM français et un modèle comme
ça c'est je dirais trois à six mois de
réflexion d'études de conception parce
que on n'a pas de plan on part de
quelques photos de quelques croquis et
ensuite il y a un mois un mois et demi
de construction à proprement parler
Geoffrey double champion de France est
venu présenter un vol en musique de deux
minutes un programme qu'il réalisera
alors des Championnats du Monde 2022 en
Lituanie synchronisation sur la musique
on essaie de suivre le rythme avec des
parties rapides et parties douces un
final il y a aussi un effet de chaux
avec des paillettes des banderoles et
pour la première fois cette année trois
accueillera les championnats régionaux
puis les championnats de France les
championnats
régionaux donc au mois de janvier qui
vont permettre à tous les pilotes de ce
qualifier et ils vont être donc d'après
ces championnats sélectionnés pour faire
partie de l'équipe de France première
fois que ça se passe dans le Grand Est
première fois que ça se passe dans
l'Aube et première fois que ça se passe
à trois les championnats régionaux
auront lieu les 14 et 15 janvier
prochain
allez zoom pour refermer ce journal sur
une autre activité originale le
bobsleigh ce sport de glisse
spectaculaire bénéficie notamment d'une
piste olympique au cœur de la station de
La Plagne une piste en pleine
préparation avant la saison hivernale du
carreau que pour 8 Mont-Blanc a
rencontré les équipes qui la
confectionnent et qui doivent s'adapter
aux enjeux actuels comme vous allez le
voir dans ce reportage glacé et glaçant
chaque automne à La Plagne c'est le même
rituel les mêmes gestes le même
savoir-faire durant 28 jours 22
personnes sont chargées de mettre en
place les 1800 mètres et 19 virages de
la pistolympique de bobsleigh
initialement bétonné la piste est
d'abord asperger d'eau tout en étant
continuellement refroidi par des tuyaux
internes une fois glacé la piste est
ensuite façonnée au millimètre près
grâce à l'expertise des employés
c'est un métier c'est tout fait à la
main s'il y a 20 ans la piste était déjà
préparée pour le mois d'octobre la date
d'ouverture est cette année prévue pour
le 10 décembre prochain avec l'actuel
crise énergétique des décisions ont en
effet dû être prise pour limiter les
coûts
historiquement en mettait l'ensemble du
dispositif l'ensemble de la piste en
froid et on produisait la glace avec sur
l'ensemble de la piste là on a changé de
stratégie en segmentant la piste en
différents secteurs suivants la charge
de travail nécessaire hormis les
entraînements sportifs la piste de
bobsleigh de La Plagne attend cet hiver
plus de 13000 touristes pour amortir la
hausse des coûts énergétiques les prix
des descentes proposés au grand public
augmenteront donc d'environ 8% par
rapport à l'année passée
voilà c'est la fin de cette édition du
Grand JT des territoires on se retrouve
très vite pour une nouvelle édition au
revoir à tous
[Musique]